John: Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday!
Today's video contains many updates about
sports and art which are supposed to be opposites,
but as we shall see today, that dichotomy
- like so many dichotomies - is a lie.
Also for reasons that will soon become clear
I have to wear a lot of shirts today.
So Hank as previously noted, I am auctioning
off my support in the World Cup this year,
which is why I recently acquired gear from
all 32 nations participating in the tournament.
Basically if you go to the link in the dooblydoo
you can essentially purchase my love on behalf
of the country of your choice.
AND your donation will be 100% tax-deductible,
provided that you live in the United States
- this isn't seriously our uniform, is it?
I don't feel like I'm about to play World
Class soccer; I feel like a six-year-old dressed
for Thanksgiving dinner.
So to date this crazy plan has raised nearly
$6,000 for Nerdfighteria's charity, the Foundation
to Decrease Worldsuck, but starting today,
all proceeds are going to benefit sarcoma
research.
Sarcoma is the kind of cancer that Augustus
Waters has in The Fault in Our Stars.
It’s also a cancer that lots of actual people
have in real life and it sucks and I hate
it, so we’re gonna raise some money to fight
sarcoma.
Here’s the deal: every time you donate one
dollar, I will donate three, so your dollar
is essentially worth four dollars AND I will
support the team of your choice in the World
Cup and I will be the most committed fan in
the world!
Unless someone else pays me more.
Like Hank, as it stands I’ll be supporting
the Ivory Coast when they play Columbia, and
to prepare myself I have already learned several
songs about Kolo Touré.
[singing] Kolo!
KOLO KOLO- right no singing.
Okay but maybe you like your soccer slightly
less professional!
Hank, remember how Nerdfighteria uses advertising
proceeds from a FIFA video series to sponsor
an actual professional football team that
fights homophobia and racism and is owned
by its fans?
Right, well Nerdfightaria-sponsored AFC Wimbledon
finished this season in 20TH, avoiding relegation
from the fourth tier of English football-
HUZZAH!
Meanwhile, the fictional AFC Wimbledon Wimbly
Womblys, led by Bald John Green, Other John
Green, Seb Brown, and Yayayabamba are putting
together a great season!
Hank, I suddenly realized how weird this must
all sound to new nerdfighters, and also to
old nerdfighters, really just to anyone, come
to think of it.
I mean the movie version of my book is coming
out in ten days, and I spend most of my free
time worrying about the health and well-being
of FIFA 14 players who are technically made
out of 1’s and 0’s.
Although to be fair, so is the movie.
Okay maybe you like games but you don’t
like soccer, by the way I think this is Argentina,
but it doesn’t show up well in this light.
Anyway, did you know that there’s an amazing
nerdfighter Minecraft server called Nerdcrafteria
that also raises money to decrease worldsuck?
Check it out!
And now, at last – let’s move on to art.
So Sarah’s new show The Art Assignment is
going great; there’s a new assignment up
from the brilliant and fascinating artist
Kate Gilmore.
And if you like talking about and/or making
art, you will find a thriving community over
at The Art Assignment, where people are making
everything from, like, gifs to sculptures.
What else is going on?
Oh right, that Nerdfighter Kiva group, that
band of suck decreasers, is very, very close
to 4 million dollars in total loans to entrepreneurs
in the developing world.
So in case you don’t know about Kiva – you
choose a business person to support, you can
make a loan for as little as $25, and then
they pay you back over time.
And if you’ve never tried it before, your
first loan is free.
It’s hard to believe we’ve almost made
4 million dollars in loans.
And of course Hank, there’s also SciShow
Space, which has a great community of space
nerds thinking and talking about our big and
beautiful and terrifying universe.
And lastly Nerfighteria’s new community
ambassador Valerie2776 has created an amazing
map and calendar of upcoming events and gatherings.
Do you have a point, John?
Yes, I have two points!
First, look how many shirts I can wear in
a single video!
Secondly, even within the tiny world of Nerdfightaria,
there are lots of ways to connect, via nerdfighter
gatherings, or if you love art, via The Art
Assignment, or if you love terrible FIFA playing,
via the Wimbly Womblys.
But Hank, at least for me, the best connections
aren’t just about feeling less alone; they’re
about finding ways to look at the universe
more broadly and enthusiastically.
Whether it’s contemporary art that takes
you there, or soccer, or building worlds in
Minecraft, or learning about space, or working
with entrepreneurs around the world, or whatever,
it’s great to feel alive to the world.
For me it’s less about what you like than
it is about how you like it.
Like, I’m not a huge fan of boxing, but
the poet Richard Katrovas is, and he once
wrote that to him, boxing serves "as a mottled
lens / Unto the bifurcated human heart / Whose
one true nature is to break apart."
Hank, I'd like to think that the human heart
has more than one true nature, but regardless,
here’s my question for you, nerdfighters
– what’s your lens these days?
I did it!
I wore all 32 shirts in a video!
Via Brasil!
Hank, I will see you on Friday.